well this movie happened and now I do
not deserve to carry my man card anymore
sinister stars Ethan Hawke he plays a
crime writer he goes out he looks for
things that happen perhaps unexplained
unsolved mysteries and he tries to solve
them with novels and he's trying to get
one more hit out of his career he moves
his family to a house in which these
four grisly murders took place and he's
trying to learn about them he's trying
to figure out what happened he finds
these film reels in the Attic and he
starts watching them discovering some
very disturbing and very creepy images
and this strange thing this guy in these
videos starts harassing him and this is
a creepy ass movie sinister is a movie
that I heard a lot of things about
because it premiered at various film
festivals and I had this buzz going
about it amongst the film nerd crowd you
know these people who love horror movies
and they want to see a good horror movie
and they're sick of the house at the end
of the street and the apparition and
just like me all these horrible horror
movies that have been coming out lately
and you see the movie's title and you
see the poster you did just everything
nowadays when it's horror it just
screams generic unfortunately but the
thing that hooked me was Ethan Hawke
he's an actor that's very underrated I
think and he rarely ever attaches
himself to garbage usually if he's in a
movie it definitely has some credibility
to it and I really enjoyed this movie
and I'll tell you why it's scary and
when a scary movie is actually scary I'm
happy I see probably like I don't know
20 to 30 horror films a year that come
out usually only a couple of them
actually are effective to me sinister is
by far the creepiest film I've seen all
year there is just a vibe in this movie
from the first shot which I may say
might be the best opening shot of the
year the opening shot of this movie is
freaking fantastic and from that opening
shot I knew I was in for something
different but like I was saying from the
opening shot of this movie onward you
just get this unsettled feeling and it's
because of the editing it's so slowly
ended like shots linger you know people
sit and they actually look like they're
thinking and and when they move you
hear the sound effects of their clothes
rippling an attention to detail of these
small little things really just make you
watch this film calmly but on edge
you're aware the fact that you're
breathing really slowly just like taking
it in and then stuff starts to happen
when I was driving home from this movie
I was kind of glancing in my rearview
mirror
I was looking behind me like what's
what's going on back there is anything
okay I'm safe
like it actually affected me and this
movie definitely put me on edge
ethan hawke i think is really good in
this movie and he's never done a
flat-out horror film before and i really
liked him his presence in this movie he
added credibility to the more
over-the-top elements of this movie
Chris did you know that this film was
written by Carlisle from spell calm yes
I did actually know that and his script
is good and I'll tell you why it is
absurd what they ask you to believe in
this movie a character sit and they talk
about things that are just so silly but
they keep this serious straight face to
it that level of dedication by the
actors and the director to that script
allows the audience to actually go okay
even though this is really silly and
over-the-top when I think about it I'm
invested right now because the way this
film is crafted and that's a testament
to the script to the actor and the
director and three of them together to
create something that normally on paper
you just be like this really better be
directed well otherwise this is going to
be stupid really stupid and I'm not
saying the script was bad it's just the
script had to have the right director
and since this movie does it worked for
me now one of the things I liked about
this movie is you can't really define it
as one specific genre yes it's
definitely a horror film or a scary film
what I mean is it's not really a ghost
movie it's not really a monster movie
it's not really a serial killer movie
it's just some paranormal thing this
being movie like I like that you
couldn't really identify what the thing
actually was so it made it more
frightening because as I revert too
often in my reviews the line from Batman
Begins where Falcone says and you always
fear what you don't understand and it's
true and the movie does have a few
issues it's by far not a perfect film a
lot of the issues I had with the film
were tonal there were times when the
movie was really riding a great line of
sustained tension and it would kind of
late for a while and then rise back up
also there are a lot of scenes of ethan
Hogg walking around at night holding a
baseball bat and in a film like the
apparition earlier this year which was
literally nothing but people walking
through halls and reacting to sound
effects and it was horribly acted and
directed and written and everything here
it seemed more real but it did get a
little tiresome after a while really not
too many problems with this movie though
I really enjoyed it I had a lot of fun
with it another thing that I really
liked was that there was a lot of added
family tension there was characters
there which made you care about the more
over-the-top scary elements because the
characters were grounded in reality and
that's how you make a good scary movie
not just brainless jocks and big
breasted women walking around half-naked
for 90 minutes
that's stupid it's not scary this film
stars a older man who is a father a
legitimate family you know characters
that seem real and so you actually are
affected by some of the scares because
of that so Chris will the movie actually
scare me
I don't know if the movie will actually
scare you I was scared by this movie and
you may be scared by it too I really
enjoyed sinister I'm gonna give it a B+
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this and you can
click right here and get stuck my next
Oh